kanye west's off oval office meeting
with President Trump sparking a media
firestorm here's a quick refresher of
what went down yesterday so they tried
to scare me to not wear this hat my own
friends but this hat it gives me it
gives me power in a way when I put this
hat off and made me feel like Superman
if he don't look good we don't look good
this is our president he has to be the
freshest the playas the BI explains but
I love this guy right here let me give
this guy the sit-down setting off CNN's
Don Lemon Don what do you think I wolf I
listen I don't there I have no animosity
for Kanye West what I saw was a minstrel
show today him in front of all of these
white people mostly white people
embarrassing himself and embarrassing
Americans but mostly African Americans
it was so hard to watch him sitting
there being used by the President of the
United States
lemon taking his disapproval a step
further by invoking the late rapper I'm
sorry the rapper's excuse me his late
mother this was an embarrassment
Kanye's mother is rolling over in her
grave I spoke to one of her friends
today or texted with one of her friends
today from Chicago Donna's friends I
used to live there I know him she said
Donda would be what would be embarrassed
by this she would be terribly disturbed
by this and penes a father figure he
needs someone to help him and to guide
him and he needs a hug more than
anything
Kanye back away from the cameras go get
some help and then come back and make
your case others in the media are also
blasting the kanye Trump summit watch
this this is such a blitzkrieg of
blathering ignorance on one level and I
say this as a man who loves Kanye West
who admires his genius and who considers
him a friend this is the kind of
conversation that would typically be
held between people wearing Hospital
bracelets
a deep sense of betrayal among people
who follow hip-hop and rap this was a
giant shiny object in the Oval Office
wearing a red hat that but if you think
you're going to get a sawed full
play-by-play and political analysis
you're not because that was an assault
on our white house then why give it all
this hype why fan the flames of the
foolish and it's not okay what happened
here celebrities are criticizing kanye
fellow rapper TI posting on instagram
quote this is the most repulsive
disgraceful embarrassing act of
desperation and auctioning off of one
soul to gain power I've ever seen and
other Hollywood stars like Chelsea
Handler and Rosie O'Donnell also
slamming the visit we could go on and on
but we want to get to the discussion
here just let me turn it over to you the
hysteria over this meeting was hot and
heavy right so if Kanye so marginalized
and so insignificant and such a clown
why is the media so angry why are they
so upset it's because he's influential
it's because he's making a lot of money
he's very talented and a lot of people
listen to him because he's very popular
and if the black community is
open-minded about President Trump then
that poses a real significant threat to
Democrats electorally the Democrats have
already written off the white
working-class they've written off
veterans they've written off key
constituents traditionally within their
party they have to drive up numbers
among minorities in order to stay
competitive with Donald Trump in 2020 so
when they see this this isn't good for
them and I remember you remember when
Kanye West said George Bush doesn't care
about black people and the same media
that's criticizing him now applauded him
back then so when you criticize as a
black man a Republican you're saying and
then when you spread love to a
Republican president you're insane I
don't like how that works and Donald
Trump won about 8% of the black vote
does that mean all those 8% of
african-american voters in this country
are crazy they're ignorant they're all
fools women who've Oh
for Donald Trump are they gender traders
Hispanics who vote for Donald rope are
they nuts - it's funny how the media and
they look really small right now they're
trying to dehumanize him when the media
says that voting as a black man for
Donald Trump is against your
self-interest who are they to determine
who's someone's self-interest why can't
black Americans determine their own
self-interest by themselves why do they
have to have the liberal media tell them
what to do and if you look at on-balance
Donald Trump's trade agenda his
manufacturing agenda his immigration
agenda is beneficial to black voters
policy wise and you can dislike him for
other things and that's fine but on
balance I think it's fair for black
Americans to say you know what I could
consider the Trump agenda made in
America make America great again yeah
and in that scenario talk about and back
in 2005 at least in the last in the
recent past Kanye West has actually
apologized for saying that the media
never what a part of the American media
and when he said that about President
Bush I was someone who definitely was
highly critical because again he didn't
know what he was talking about so here
you come and you say oh why can't black
people be open mind about President
Trump this and that hey guess what Jesse
by your own measure 92 percent of black
people said our self-interest is not
being served by the agenda being
promoted by let's pray and think for
himself
no he if he was thinking for himself he
would have had some substantive argument
to make instead here's what he said
Jesse yeah oh I put on this hat and it
gives me super power I really want a
father figure and then you know he's
separated by the desk he has to get up
and walk around front don't even get up
to hug the guy he's they're hugging
Trump like he's holding on he's trying
to get something out of this
so he's Jimmy Brown let me finish did I
interrupt come on man so what I'm saying
to you is you hear this man say stuff
like Oh Trump's on a hero's journey
maybe he's on a following
I don't know but it all it looked like
was some guy ranting and I am you know
personally offended by the kind of
profanity he brought there I don't
understand how anybody said it's a bigot
but I don't get this
when you had people like common jay-z
kendrick lamar doing things with
president obama the right-wing went nuts
they said these guys are rappers some of
them associate with thugs and gangsters
hey what about this guy all of a sudden
the man who was insulted republicans the
man who has nothing to say other than
his hat gives a superpower is a
republican hero this is ridiculous it's
absurd and Don Lemon Amen this is
someone who is a shameful example of
behavior in the presence of a powerful
shameful ally went after his mom like
that you never go after someone's mother
one you didn't go after his mother you
know that was a cheap audience here by
the way maybe they don't shot it wasn't
you distort this whole conversation this
was not about black people or about his
impact on the black vote this is about
how white Americans who say hey Trump
has problems with race feel about Trump
now Trump says hey look the America I
got a black friend in a red okay you
guys I'm gonna have to interrupt the
reason I was looking like that is
because we have tape from President
Trump watch from Turkey he's I think in
good shape he'll be stopping most likely
in Germany for a full checkup and then
he's going to be coming to the Oval
Office most likely on Saturday but we're
very honored to have him back with us he
he suffered greatly but we're very
appreciative to a lot of people a lot of
people so pastor Brunson's
in the air heading to Germany and then
coming to the US he'll be landing on
Saturday most likely Saturday in DC well
we we spoke to Turkey and he went
through a system and we get him out
they've been trying to get him out for a
long time
well this has nothing to do with
anything there was no deal made at all
there was no deal but we're very happy
to have him and have him in good shape I
hear he's in very good shape
you'll be evaluating the relationship
with Saudi Arabia well we're going to
find out what happened with respect to
the terrible situation in Turkey having
to do with Saudi Arabia and the reporter
and nobody knows quite yet nobody's been
able to put it all together people are
starting to form ideas and as they're
formed we'll let you know but it
certainly is a terrible thing and
overlooked for too long excuse me that's
their record otherwise been overlooked
for Chile I think a lot of records are
overlooked if you look at Iran if you
look at so many other countries take a
look at Syria you take a look at a lot
of countries a lot of countries records
have been overlooked but this is a very
serious thing and we're looking at it in
a very serious manner okay and we'll see
you we have a big crowd I will I will be
calling them I will be calling at some
point King Salman you know you're right
and you're right in the way of their
camera behind you I'm sure they they
think you're a very good looking guy but
maybe not that good from the back right
all right so go ahead it's a you plan to
call him soon I think speaking to him
yes pretty soon well I can't tell you
but I will say that they are looking
very hard and fast and not only us a lot
of people are looking to find out
because it it is potentially a really
really terrible situation so we'll see
what happens
that's it for Tara to develop such a
close relationship was it a mistake for
Jared to develop such a close I don't
know if it's any closer than other
relationships that people have we have a
lot of very close relationships with a
lot of countries but this is a serious
problem thank you well I guess a lot of
people are going over to an investment
country said he actually called this
morning and he will make that
determination but he was partially over
there anyway a lot of people are going
over to the investment conference we'll
see what happens maybe some won't be
going
we'll make that determination very soon
okay we'll see you over at the rally
climate report yet President Trump
talking about pastor Brunson
the American who was released from a
kept market captivity was being held by
the the Turkish government and now he is
going to be returned to America the
president says he should be back in DC
by Saturday he said probably Saturday
he's got to stop in Germany he's gonna
get a check-up and then he will be
returning to America as well that is a
big win for the Trump administration and
every American should be glad that
Pastor Brunson is being returned to
America he never should have been held
in the first place we're gonna get back
to the story we were talking about Jesse
and Juan had a chance to talk about
Kanye West meeting in the Oval Office
and the reaction to it and then Greg and
Jedediah hadn't had a chance we'll go to
Greg first well first good news about
the pastor it shows what happens when
you have a president president who
doesn't blink they knew that he wasn't
going to change his mind
the economy is in a freefall yeah so
here's the that I want to address the
the central argument that lemon has and
others have when you describe somebody
as a minstrel or as a prop I've learned
in my life that any criticism that can
be applied everywhere is useless it's
pointless for example I could just as
easily look at Don Lemon and say wow CNN
pulled out their prop they needed they
needed somebody to talk about Kanye so
they called up the black guy so you can
see you can use this you can use this
here on the 5:00 with Juan you can call
I can call you a prop but I would never
do that the fact is this sort of
criticism can be applied anywhere that
there are blacks and whites together
that's my point
wherever you see an olive branch between
a black person and a white person
somebody can say the whites using him as
a minstrel and the black is seeking
power you can say that now for
everything and that's why it's so
dangerous why not just take it for what
it is what you're seeing people actually
having a dialogue when you reduce
somebody to a minstrel or you make or
you you have the gall to actually bring
up his late mother to make a point it
would you use his late mother as some
kind of vessel for your own envy what I
saw there limb I saw lemon who felt limp
a person who felt ineffectual who felt
that he's not part of the game so he
sees
going on in the white house and lemon in
his brain is saying why can't that be me
that's not fair
I should be there and so he went after
this guy because this guy has the guts
to stand up and take the slings and
arrows if CNN were around two thousand
years ago the sea would stand for
crucify him Janet uh what do you think
about especially the comments that he is
mentally ill and yeah that to me felt a
little over the line over the wine and
what bothers me about this is that
they've infantilized Kanye this is a guy
who's been very successful he's a
successful businessman he went in there
he wasn't just talking nonsense as some
of said he was talking about stop and
frisk he was talking about what he cares
about I mean what do you think all these
celebrities that went into the Obama
White House you think they were all
policy experts they all went in and they
sat down and they were a dana perino
know they had an opinion they cared
about issues they went in they made
their case the criticism from the right
was not personal attacks of those people
it was not saying things which have been
said about Kanye that he's dumb that
he's sick that he's a madman that he's a
traitor all of that has been said about
Kanye people were saying when would
folks on the Left were going in
celebrities on the left were going in to
meet with Obama and all that the
commentary was well this is typical
because you know Democrats in Hollywood
are hand-in-hand no one was going out
there and saying personal attacks Oh Oh
George Clooney is mentally unstable this
is over the line
this is because they cannot handle
dissent they cannot handle sand as
someone who has lived in New York City
for whole I have I taught it I went to
Columbia University I taught in liberal
academia I can tell you that when you
stand out there is a pattern on the left
of having to marginalize that person of
having to point out that there's
something wrong with them of having to
drive them out they are now trying to
ruin this guy's career and ruin his
credibility and they're gonna stop at
nothing and I have a real problem with
that whether I agree with Kanye or not
that type of behavior should not be
accepted by the way Gregg I just I don't
I just don't want it to go without
comment that I don't think I'm a token
or but you seem like you seem like they
are you say you're a point because I
don't think anybody would say that to
you great no any time I don't think that
given my record as a journalist I don't
think there's any way that you'd say oh
but Jesus Juan Williams I'm talking
about the superfish
looking at news you're looking at color
and going oh there's a black person on
white person using new wear as a white
person I wouldn't say I would say listen
might be a Chokin this is what Jared I
was saying let's look at the substance
let's make a date exactly and when I
looked at the substance I saw nothing
but a public relations stunt put on by
the president and maybe Kanye designing
it helped his reputation and the token
short person the token male-specific all
right